phase one is the pre data or menu data
this is the first set of screens that
the user sees and needed to be loaded
immediately in grits all of our menu
assets are defined and positioned in
HTML so the browser will handle loading
of these assets as part of parsing and
processing the HTML file for
presentation since these assets are
defined in the Dom their loading is
handled by the browser's page parser and
handler so we don't have to do anything
explicit here once the user hits join
game we enter into a new face we must
load all the scripting data that's used
by the game the data hasn't been defined
by the Dom as such we need to issue
commands to our asset loader to fetch
that information and wait until it's
been loaded it's worth pointing out that
the game scripting and menu scripting
are really two separate code bases which
is why we load them separately as well
the scripting code will load up the
object definitions systems physics etc
and all of the other things we need to
run the game but not needed during menu
browsing so here is a list of scripts
that we use inside of grits what we'd
like you to do is pass the array of file
names to the asset manager as a batch
operation to load all of the data after
the batch is entirely loaded call window
alert to notify the player that the
files are loaded